et comme d'habitude ça commence enfin à
vous on vous ramène à se passer de la
tène est-ce que vous en avez marre qu'on
vous parle de la n2 kassovitz où c'est
quelque chose que voilà qui a été
tellement important pour vous que vous
l'accepter c'est drôle de revoir ses
j'avais jamais revu ses missions c'est
ma première télévision non ça fait
partie de ma vie c'est une partie
importante de ma vie
après bon il faut passer à autre chose
mais j'en suis tellement fier le film
est devenu culte pour tellement de
génération et pour tous les ghettos du
monde bizarrement puisque la violence la
tristesse tout ça c'est c'est un peu la
même partout les rues se ressemblent
énormément mais non c'est certes un très
très beau film et qui continue de parler
à des générations qui est encore
d'actualité quand on le voit on a
présenté a été tourné hier c'est un
problème réel sociale très compliquée
donc si ça peut aider les gens à mieux
comprendre tout cela non avec grand
poucet très fier de ce fier de pouvoir
lier de ghettos quand je disais m'a dit
qu'il était passé lé rôle de dealer à
celui de président de la république mais
c'est rare est ce que pour sortir de ce
ghetto auquel on consomme souvent les
acteurs arabes il fallait s'exiler aux
états unis où vous pensez qu'en france
vous aurez été cantonné peut-être même
pas seulement aux rôles d'armes et au
rôle d'arabe de banlieue de cité bah oui
je pense qu'en général mais en france on
met les gens ont souvent dans des cases
quand tu démarres en pin up et ben tu
finis en pin up c'est très difficile
mais tout le challenge est là justement
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
comment tu changes le truc et et sinon
tu es un peu routinier et c'est dur mais
travaille dans un bureau c'est un peu la
même chose
donc c'est le challenge et c'était un
vrai challenge
j'arrive toujours pas y croire en fait
quand je me lève le matin je me dis
waouh
mais avec la fois avec le travail avec
la passion avec le talent avec les
rencontres
et puis voilà tu montes une marche une
deuxième une troisième et puis c'est pas
fini et puis et puis c'est le début le
meilleur reste à venir une aura votre
regard sur saïd taghmaoui basset a
toujours un peu impressionnante vous
rencontrer mais moi j'ai l'impression
que même aux états unis on
vous n'avez pas encore eu le rôle que
vous méritez j'ai l'impression qu'on
fait toujours un peu les mêmes rôles
souvent c'est des méchants semences et
des films d'action est ce que vous
n'attendez pas aussi un rôle où on
pourrait enfin vous découvrir autrement
alors d'abord l'important quand on est
acteur en tout cas pour moi c'est de
travailler
le danger c'est pas les rôles de
méchants ou c'est les stéréotypes et les
clichés c'est ça qu'ils sont mais les
rôles extrêmes
c'est formidable ma part au prochain
robert de niro et de faire le
psychopathe ou taxi driver ou où la
franchise parce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les sais quelle forme ça prend
après il faut faire quelques sacrifices
dans la vie tu te dis tiens c'est
peut-être pas le plus beau rôle du monde
mais ça va me permettre de rebondir et
donc tu apprends ton métier tu
rencontres des gens j'ai quand même été
capable très rapidement de faire
quelques rôles de terroristes très
intéressant des terroristes alors
médecin qui est super même tragédie
grecque etc alors vraiment intéressant
avec une vraie profondeur où on creuse
le personnage etc
on n'est pas dans le cliché encore ce
que c'est ça qui est vraiment dangereux
ensuite j'ai fait des trucs de super
héros aussi formidable avec diageo ou
dans wonder woman
j'ai fait des films historiques
incroyable comme celui là qu'on voit à
la télé
enfin mais je vais encore rôle dans un
woody allen dans ses collègues
c'est pas une obligation ces personnes a
jeté une obligation l'annoncé de
rencontrer âme un rôle ou cacao c'est
l'honnêteté en fait la base c'est de se
dire tiens je peux apporter quelque
chose à ce personnes et sahil c'est vous
qui avait placé la barre très haut
moitié sérieusement mais pas
plaisanterie vous dis je m'arrêterai pas
avant l'oscar donc on se dit l'oscar ça
passe par des rôles encore le cran au
dessus même si on savait que comédie
aussi à me prendre toutes les formes aux
fêtes dont on apprend encore un peu plus
de temps je n'ai que du respect pour ces
tags wybran que du respect c'est
mitterand qui on ne peut rien contre la
volonté d'un homme
il s'est inventé sur mesure une carrière
quand même fou d'imaginer qu'il a été
plus simple de faire la chose la plus
compliquée cyr changer de langue changer
de pays
changer de culture pour réussir donc de
rester en france faire des films de
banlieue jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
d'abord il est encore jeune charles
bronson a commencé à 52 à 49 ans était
une fois dans l'ouest
je pense qu'il a effectivement toute sa
carrière devant lui il aura le scar s'il
le veut il l'aura bon certes admet oui a
toujours eu ce qu'il veut surtout
non mais merci bien vous je viens de
regarder regarder les solos de guitare
mais ce qu'on voit passer des milliers
d'heures qu'il a passées à faire du
solfège à faire des accords et à faire
des gammes et je sais que c'est un
énorme travailleur qui d'ailleurs est
très modeste et très humble il ne fait
jamais de bruit xterra il se concentre
sur ses films il ya chez lui aucun
cynisme n'ya que de l'énergie moi j'ai
tout à fait confiance dans la suite de
sa carrière devant moi je trouve ça
prend du temps et que et que c'est pas
un sprinter un marathon et que ça prend
beaucoup de temps
le prochain film qu'on va tourner c'est
dans deux semaines au maroc et on arrive
c'est l'adaptation d'un livre
exceptionnel de osbourne qui s'appelle
de faux given est donc dans le casting
il ya jessica chase tonnes liam neeson
et ralph fiennes et ont dit on va dire
sur le tournage on prend tout doucement
mais ça prend du temps il faut il faut
il faut faire naître le désir c'est tous
ces grands metteurs en scène
en arrivant dans le studio et
aujourd'hui j'ai vu des photos
formidable dernier
lino ventura il y avait jean gabin mais
ils sont où tous ces gens aujourd'hui
sont morts qui se négocie une émission
d'information
[Rires]
la misère est ce que vous pensez d'un
film comme les misérables alors les
misérables je les ai vus aux etats unis
puisque je suis membre de l'académie des
oscars et donc je vais aller voter et je
regarde tous les films et c'est des
heures de travail pour aller travailler
tout à l'heure c'est des heures et des
heures de travail j'aime je connais la
dgi viens je vais rencontrer à los
angeles c'est un ami je trouve que ça
fait avancer les choses j'ai pas trouvé
que c'est le meilleur film au monde sur
le sujet mais ça c'est le cinéaste c'est
le l'acteur qui parle c'est le
professionnel mais j'ai trouvé que
c'était quand même du bon côté de la
force après cinématographiquement
j'aurai d'autres choses à dire parce que
je suis j'écris moi même et que et que
j'aime profondément le cinéma et que
j'ai une ambition très forte par rapport
à tout cela
isabelle une carrière à l'étranger vous
avez envisagé ou est ce que vous
envisagez maintenant une carrière à
l'étranger votre diction en anglais ça
doit être mortels je pense qu'ils vont
être complètement amoureux de vous oui
c'est vrai qu'elle fasse en allemagne
parce qu'en allemagne par contre on est
si beau dit je le dis très bien mais ce
qu'on peut faire avec isabelle en
amérique s'est adapté ses pièces en
anglais et ça ça deviendrait un tel jour
et elle même après le joue elle-même où
elle donne à d'autres gens apprécient l
cuba je devais faire qui vous trouve
très beau
le remake à bon et alors non mais une
fois qu'un film effet il est fait ou on
étire pas le trump mais j'ai
l'impression quand même que le cinéma
n'a guère général vous le délaissé pour
le théâtre et c'est justement parce que
c'est trop long à mettre en place qui a
trop d'intermédiaires que vous qui
parlez de contrainte c'est encore plus
dur
scénario est modifié par un producteur
et placez vous avez fait trois films ou
de séries c'est dire que le suspense de
du résultat du film à 14 heures sa tombe
voilà que vous gagnez que vous gagnez
pas un c'est comme les cours 5 quand
votre cheval vous mettez de l'argent sur
votre cheval vous vous demandez s'il
arrivait tout la magie le coeur bat le
coeur et même quand ils arrivent premier
jeu j'ai du mal à me remettre pareil là
je trouve que là c'est là c'est tombé
la sentence est tombée à 14 ans avec eux
ça les savais pas que ça allait aller si
loin que ça marcherait mais c'est cet
attentat aux angoisses trop après 30 ans
à l'angoissé
au théâtre on peut toujours rectifier et
puis si rigolo quoi qu'ils aient envie
de rigoler et puis ça vit sa vie comme
un bon cuir non ça se tanne avec le
temps où un bon vin le théâtre c'est
vrai que le cinéma c'est tellement une
fois pour paris c'est tellement violent
6 à 14 heures tapas fait se tendent
entre mais c'est terrible et gagnon qui
est pas gagné c'est ça c'est là c'est la
tactique à sneek saïd j'ai deux
dernières questions pour vous la
première qu'est ce qui reste de français
on vous quand on s'abandonne quand on
abandonne ce qui as que je deviens
vraiment un acteur américain où il reste
quand même quelque chose de l'acteur
alors sans l'amérique devait vous
assimilez au point d'oublier
non non non c'est au contraire c'est ce
qui te rends tu justement tu as
singularité et c'est là bas que je me
rends compte que je suis vraiment
français puisque tout me manque que ce
soit ma famille que ce soit mes
habitudes
ce soit le fromage enfin tout tu veux
pas imaginer ces barricades l'ec raismes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc je dors en gilet jaune est évident
mais c'est vrai que il ya qui se passe
c'est que tu te rappelles à ta culture
et c'est ce qui te donne cette force
aussi et il se passe un truc il ya un
déclic c'est le moment où tu commences à
rêver dans la langue du pays
et c'est là où tu commences à t'éloigner
vraiment du truc et tu te dis tiens
merde j'ai fait un rêve en anglais pour
de vrai quoi et tu vois que tu lui
parles hyper couramment en anglais dans
le truc mais l'on te réponde et c'est
super normal
une dernière question c'est le plus
important je crois que c'est très ami
avec marc valberg de ce papa amis c'est
mon frère c'est un problème personnel
j'ai un faveur des demandes et il se
trouve que ma femme était
inexplicablement amoureuse ça le met
dans tous ses états est ce que vous
pourriez dire face caméra qu'en fait
c'est un sale con parce que c'est très
pénible
je passe des trucs très très difficile
réveil marqué au réveil et comme tout le
monde
voilà il va aux toilettes comme tout le
merci vraiment c'était plus important je
rappelle saïd taghmaoui qu on vous
retrouve dans quelques mois je pense à
sortir en français le 3 juin dans wonder
woman 1904 et on viendra du bois
[Applaudissements]